عاد ثعلوب المحتال
نَحْنُ صِغَارٌ نَحْنَ صِغَارْ *** وَلَدَيْنَا بَعْضُ الاَفْكَارْ
وَكَشَفْنَا بِذَكَاءٍ مِنَّا ***  حِيَلَ الثَّعْلَوبِ المَكَّارْ
مَرَّةْ جَاءَ و دَقَّ البَابْ ***  يَلْبَسُ مِثْلَ الجَدَّهْ ثِيَابْ
لَكِنْ جَدَّتَنَا المَحْبُوبَهْ ***  لاَ تَمْلِكُ تِلْكَ الأنْيَابْ
عاد ثعلوب المحتال
أَيْضًا جَاءَ بِشَكْلِ مُهَرِّجْ  ***  وَيُرِيدُ إِلَيْهِ أَنْ نَخْرُ جْ
وَوَحِيدًا دُونَ أَطْفَالٍ ***  حَوْلَهُ بِسَعَادَةْ تَتَفَرَجْ
نَحْنُ صِغَارٌ نَحْنَ صِغَارْ *** وَلَدَيْنَا بَعْضُ الاَفْكَارْ
وَكَشَفْنَا بِذَكَاءٍ مِنَّا ***  حِيَلَ الثَّعْلَوبِ المَكَّارْ
أَحْرَجْنَا دَوْمًا ثَعْلُوبْ  ***  أَضْحَكَنَا بِالخَارِجِ نَطَّهْ
أَرْعَبَهُ بَابَا سَنْجُوبْ ***  لَمَّا أَمَامَ المَنْزِلِ ضَبَطَهْ
أَدْرَكْنَا بِالفِطْنَةِ حِيَلَهْ ***  يأتينا ولاَ يَسْتُرُ ذَيْلَهْ
وَلَهُ صَوْتٌ خَشِنٌ مُرْعِبْ ***  لاَ يُحْسِنُ أَصْوَاتًا بَدَلَهْ
مَامَا قَالَتْ يَا أَحْبَابْ ***  ثَعْلُوبٌ دَوْمًا كَذَّابْ
أَعْطَتْنَا صُوَرًا لِلْمَاكِرِ***   مُلْصَقَةً لَهُ خَلْفَ البَابْ